Yeah, Jason from Jubilee here, and we have a big announcement.
We're partnering with good to vote,
and we're trying to get a hundred new voter registrations.
If you help us to hit this goal,
we're going to do one new episode of odd man out with any topic that you guys
help us choose. Uh,
we think that the election is super important and it's really important for all
of us to just be involved with a political process.
We hope to see you out there voting,
and we're excited to make a new episode for you fraud man, out for now.
Enjoy the episode.
How can you tell if someone is a fifth grader through their knowledge of video
games, TV shows or social media influencers,
maybe it's by how much they know about slime.
Is it through the subjects they might be learning in school or is it just by how
they look? We brought together six, fifth graders.
I am fifth grader.
I'm a fifth grader. I am a fifth grader. I am a fifth grader.
I am a fifth grader.
And tried something different. On this episode,
we brought two moles where college kids with no cameras,
can the fifth graders find the odd man out.
I feel like the college student is going to have a bigger vocabulary.
And also going to ask if you guys have ticked off,
because I think a lot of people have ticked off at our age to take a college
student. I don't know, we're both tutors.
So we kind of have that little inside scoop.
I don't want to have any suspicions of anyone yet, but that's true to change.
I'm going to go, Hey Gordon,
is that what a child looks at? What is your
face? People just have like 10 questions. I'm a mama, mama, mama,
mom at the mall. Where am I?
If it's a college kid,
I feel like they wouldn't be in school because college is
called to that. Amy misspelled something.
So she can't be coached a lesson. She's trying to art.
I've never seen a fifth grader uses multiple exclamation or
I think I suspect Gordon is typing.
It's all uppercase letters and that's college student typing.
I'm this girl with people who names sound like college names.
It's talking about biology. We haven't stood bales yet.
So I'm not sure about that. Oh, he's interrogating people.
Gordon seems suspicious.
Who said they weren't biology. They're going to Feb.
I think what Kayla is going to get out and Zoe is not
okay. I'm trusting now. Okay. I think we're good. I think that they will be,
I don't know how we're going to read.
So I'm going to vote for Gordon.
He used writing that I would use in like school.
I'm probably going to vote for McKayla. Okay.
That was a college student names. I don't trust you. College unit.
There's a lot of strong vocabulary or what?
He says his ages Akila, because you know,
she's more suspicious than McKayla because I all edgy and everyone
else was like biology. Cause he said, yeah,
I haven't done that yet. Fifth grade. And I was like,
why would you say in fifth grade,
are you trying to make me think you're in fifth grade.
The votes are in.
And we have a tie to the two people with the most votes right now
are Gordon.
[Inaudible]. I am doing Gordon again. McKayla, McKayla.
I'm doing boarding again.
And the person eliminated this round is
Gordon.
They didn't expect that. I probably shouldn't have used as much grammar.
Okay. Charlie Mila. Your favorite YouTuber, if you watch YouTube, of course.
Cause I know not everyone watch it. You choose YouTube.
Let's see what they ask us. Yeah. And then we'll add, I'll ask I'll answer.
I'm nervous. I like noodles,
singles, stranger cheese.
I only get an hour
a day,
four screens an hour,
only four screens through blocks. Don't play road blocks.
But I feel like if I say that,
they'll think that in the college student I've been really tied up on this chat.
I love robots. I love tech talk.
My favorite show is stranger things. That's
my favorite take. Took her. I don't have tic-tac for hours, but more on weekend.
I can stay on for as long as I like. Oh my mom says to get off. I don't know.
I'm going crazy. You guys in this chat, I'm going crazy.
Did you guys know custom plays? You're grounded grabbed it.
You're grounded. You're grounded.
I don't know anything that they're telling me about. Yes.
I love Preston Preston. Oh,
Kristen's like a game. So
hang on here. This is going too fast.
Everyone was spoken about the Mason, roadblocks, Minecraft.
We didn't really answer any tech top questions because we thought their age.
They're not allowed to have to call because you're asleep 13 and older.
I don't know. I just kept saying like, yeah. So funny. Ha ha.
I'm surprised I made it. I think I choose Zoe.
She didn't talk very much. Makeda I'm suspicious of
Sandra because she talks a lot and she just trying to get people to not think
she's talking Micah. He is very, very suspicious.
Okay. The person eliminated this round.
McKayla. It doesn't feel good to be eliminated. It's more words.
I don't know how they keep letting her slide. I did not see the name.
This is such a cheesy photo.
It looks a lot like is an emoji. No,
it looks like greater. And second of all, it wasn't taken long ago.
Amy said, you look so cool. So I said, cool. Oh, Sandra said,
do you play basketball? I said, yes. You can't run over. Like I say guys,
Oh my goodness gracious.
Wow, man,
that looks like very good quality. So all Sandra's a girl.
If I look at it, like it ease a college student,
then I can see it being a college student.
But if I look at it as a fifth grader, I can also see it as a fifth grader.
Nice. That means a lot.
She said so cute. So I need you to live with me. Same type of camera's me. Wait,
what? Use the same type of camera as me. How does he know that? Oh goodness.
I don't know. I don't know. No, no, no.
I got, I think it's her.
She's got pink tails are really worn over
Amy. I'm going for you.
[inaudible] yeah, we don't want that to get into that.
It's not like a sixth grader though. I'm probably voting Micah for this round.
I'm the only person that my full body in the picture. How
they're definitely going to suspect me or aren't they, I suppose. Nice.
You want me to set up you swag?
Well, all of them looked like a child. This is going to be a very hard decision.
It's Amy. Cause I seen that picture before.
I've seen it somewhere. Micah,
because in his photo he looks very mature.
All of a sudden in her picture.
I couldn't really tell whether she was a college student or a fifth grader, Amy.
Because usually when people look back at their old photos, we say do,
and that's what she said and why it's not Amy.
Then I don't know. I seen it somewhere.
I've seen it somewhere.
And the person eliminated on round three is Amy.
Amy.
I knew that this was an IVR. And why didn't you say
well, now we could have found another picture. Oh my gosh.
And a fifth grader because I play with slime. I do roadblocks.
I ride my scooter. I like fantasy books. And lastly,
because I do ballet,
I'm a fifth grader because I just graduated from fourth grade last year and I am
working on double,
double doubles and I love to play Roblox and Minecraft and I love to watch plus
in plays and think noodles and Ninjago and Phineas.
And I'm a fifth grader because last year I was in fourth grade,
my favorite movie is frozen too.
And my favorite TV show is avatar. Last Airbender.
If you don't believe me, my class,
my fifth grade classroom number is five three, two, four.
I am a fifth grader because I liked to play way too many
video games.
I knew way too many classes and I hate them.
I hate them with all my heart. Um,
teachers said that he has too many classes and I played way too much roadblocks
on my computer. She is a fifth grader guys,
my friends, fifth grader right there. We're all fifth graders. We
Go for Micah. It's not him, but I'm gonna vote. Prem. Mike has said,
I have too many classes and I hate them too many classes
means he's hot with college.
I would choose Micah just because his voice sounds a little bit older than any
of ours. Everyone's voice talent different. It didn't sound like they were like,
[inaudible].
The person eliminated this round is Micah.
Ooh, really feel bad for Mike.
All right. In Zoe and Hollis. Sandra,
give me a thumbs up.
If you want to continue the game or give me a thumbs down.
If you think you caught the mole and you want to end the game here.
I think we've caught them all. I think we're all fifth graders take.
Everyone's been saying
this is rarely. I'm very, very nervous.
Okay. Everyone has done thumbs down. You guys have voted. No.
So we are going to end the game theory.
You guys believe that you guys already caught. The mole.
Really helped me feeling
and confident. Let's go, come on. Let's do it.
The box is green. You win. And if the boxes are red,
the mall is still in the game and you guys lost. Okay.
In three.
[Inaudible].
So everyone turned on your cameras in three, two, one.
[Inaudible] it's Amy. Katie I'm Iris.
Wait,
how did you guys know? Do you ever not grammatical at all?
It was all because of the picture. The photo you posted. Yeah.
Do we look like we're in college? No.
You look like at the end of high school. True younger.
I think he was like a year in middle school. Oh, is that a compliment?
Yes. Thanks guys.
Something about being special about a fifth grader is,
I don't know. It's like the head of the elementary school. You're the top.
We're not too young to be considered a tiny child.
It's basically the midway in life. No.
And say that like 30 years old is the midway, but yeah.
Close to like the midway between child and teenager,
they were all really funny. A lot of them are very intelligent. I don't know.
It was fun. It was great experience. Obviously want to win,
but I'm glad the kids got money. Yeah.
It seemed like bad college students stealing money from little kids.